Yo trabajo con una especie llamada bonobo.
Y estoy feliz la mayor parte del tiempo,
porque creo que esta es la especie más feliz del planeta.
Es un secreto bien guardado.
Esta especie sólo vive en el Congo.
Y no están en muchos zoológicos debido a su comportamiento sexual.
Su conducta sexual se parece demasiado a la humana,
lo que deja incómodos a muchos.
(Risas)
Pero...
en realidad, tenemos mucho que aprender de ellos porque
son una sociedad muy igualitaria y empática.
Y su comportamiento sexual no se limita a un aspecto de su vida
que separan de otras áreas.
Está presente en todos los aspectos de su vida.
Y se usa para la comunicación.
Y se usa para la resolución de conflictos.
Y creo que quizás en algún punto de nuestra historia
dividimos nuestras vidas en muchas partes.
Dividimos nuestro mundo en un montón de categorías.
Y así, todo tiene una especie de lugar donde debe encajar.
Pero no creo que fuéramos así en un principio.
Hay muchos que piensan que el mundo animal está gobernado por reglas fijas
y que el hombre tiene algo muy, muy especial.
Quizás sea su capacidad de pensar causalmente.
Tal vez sea algo especial en su cerebro
que le permite tener lenguaje.
que le permite fabricar herramientas o tener matemáticas.
Bueno, no sé, alrededor del 1600 se descubrió
una tribu en Tasmania y no tenían fuego.
No tenían herramientas de piedra.
Hasta donde sabemos, no tenían música.
Así que, si los comparamos con los bonobo,
el bonobo es un poco más peludo.
No se para tan erguido.
Pero hay muchas similitudes.
Y creo que al observar la cultura,
podemos comprender
cómo llegamos a donde estamos.
Y no creo que sea por nuestra biología.
Creo que lo atribuimos a nuestra biología
pero no creo que realmente sea eso.
Así que ahora quiero presentarles
a la especie llamada bonobo.
Este es Kanzi.
Él es un bonobo.
En este momento está en un bosque en Georgia.
Su madre es originaria de un bosque en África.
Ella vino a nosotros cuando tenía unos seis o siete años de edad,
justo en su pubertad.
Aquí vemos un bonobo a su derecha
y un chimpancé a su izquierda.
Evidentemente, el chimpancé tiene más dificultad al caminar.
El bonobo, aunque más bajo y de brazos más largos que nosotros,
está más erguido, como nosotros.
Esto compara un bonobo con un australopitecino como Lucy.
Como pueden ver no hay mucha diferencia
entre la forma de caminar de un bonobo
y la forma en que un australopitecino primitivo habría caminado.
Al girar hacia nosotros verán
que el área pélvica del australopitecino primitivo es un poco más plana
y no tiene que rotar tanto de un lado a otro.
Por lo tanto, le es un poco más fácil caminar bípedamente.
Y ahora vemos a los cuatro.
Vídeo: El bonobo salvaje vive en África central, en la selva
rodeada por el río Congo.
Frondosos árboles que llegan a los 40 metros o 130 pies
cubren densamente la zona.
El primero en realizar estudios de campo serios
sobre el bonobo fue un científico japonés,
hace casi tres décadas.
Los bonobo son ligeramente más pequeños que los chimpancés.
Delgados, los bonobo son por naturaleza criaturas pacíficas.
Largos y minuciosos estudios nos han develado nuevos descubrimientos.
Un descubrimiento fue que a menudo los bonobo salvajes caminan en dos patas.
Aún más, son capaces de caminar erguidos por largas distancias.
"Saludemos a Austin y, a continuación, vayamos al cuadro A."
Susan Savage-Rumbaugh: Estos somos Kanzi y yo en el bosque.
Nada de lo que verán en este video fue aprendido por entrenamiento.
No hay ningún truco.
Todo fue capturado en video espontáneamente
por la NHK de Japón.
Tenemos ocho bonobos.
Vídeo: "Mira todas las cosas para nuestra fogata."
SS: Una familia entera en nuestro centro de investigación.
Video: "¿Vas a ayudar a juntar palos?
Bien.
También necesitamos más palos.
Tengo un encendedor en el bolsillo si lo necesitas.
Eso es un avispero.
Puedes sacarlo.
Espero tener un encendedor.
Puedes usar el encendedor para prender el fuego."
SS: A Kanzi le interesa mucho el fuego.
Aún no lo prende sin un encendedor,
pero creo que si viera a alguien hacerlo, podría ser capaz de
hacer un fuego sin un encendedor.
Está aprendiendo cómo mantener un fuego encendido.
Está aprendiendo los usos del fuego
simplemente viendo lo que hacemos nosotros con el fuego.
(Risas)
Esta es una sonrisa en el rostro de un bonobo.
Estas son vocalizaciones de alegría.
Video: "Estás feliz.
Lo que estás haciendo te hace muy feliz.
Debes poner un poco de agua sobre el fuego. ¿Ves el agua?
Buen trabajo."
SS: Olvidó cerrar su mochila completamente.
Pero le gusta llevar cosas de un lugar a otro.
Video: "Austin, te oigo decir Austin."
SS: Habla con otros bonobos en el laboratorio, a distancia,
más lejos de lo que podemos oír.
Esta es su hermana.
Esta es la primera vez que trata de conducir un carro de golf.
Vídeo: "Adiós."
(Risas)
SS: Entendió los pedales, pero no el volante.
Cambia de reversa a avance
y se sujeta al volante, en lugar de girarlo.
(Risas)
Como nosotros, sabe que el individuo en el espejo es ella misma.
(Música)
Vídeo: Al criar bonobos en una cultura a la vez bonobo y humana
y documentar su desarrollo a través de dos décadas,
los científicos estudian cómo las fuerzas culturales
(Risas)
pueden haber operado durante la evolución humana.
Su nombre es Nyota.
Significa estrella en swahili.
(Música)
Panbanisha intenta cortarle el pelo a Nyota con un par de tijeras.
En la naturaleza, los padres bonobo suelen acicalar a sus crías.
Aquí Panbanisha usa tijeras en lugar de sus manos,
para acicalar a Nyota.
Muy impresionante.
Se necesitan maniobras sutiles de las manos
para realizar tareas delicadas como esta.
Nyota intenta imitar a Panbanisha usando las tijeras del mismo modo.
Consciente de que Nyota podría lastimarse,
Panbanisha, como cualquier madre humana,
cuidadosamente intenta sacárselas.
Ya puede cortar a través de cuero grueso.
SS: Kanzi ha aprendido a hacer herramientas de piedra.
Vídeo: Kanzi ahora fabrica sus herramientas,
del mismo modo que nuestros antepasados podrían
haberlas hecho hace dos millones y medio de años atrás;
sujetando las piedras con ambas manos y golpeándolas entre sí.
Aprendió que si usa ambas manos
y apunta dónde hacer estos golpes oblicuos
puede hacer trozos mucho más grandes y afilados.
Kanzi elige un trozo que cree está suficientemente afilado.
El cuero es difícil de cortar, incluso con un cuchillo.
La roca que está utilizando Kanzi es extremadamente dura
e ideal para hacer herramientas de piedra, pero difícil de manejar;
requiere gran habilidad.
La roca de Kanzi es de Gona, Etiopía
y es idéntica a las utilizadas por nuestros antepasados africanos
dos millones y medio de años atrás.
Estas son las piedras que Kanzi utilizó
y estos son los trozos que fabricó.
Los bordes afilados son como los filos de un cuchillo.
Comparémoslos con las herramientas de nuestros antepasados:
tienen un gran parecido con las de Kanzi.
Panbanisha anhela ir a dar un paseo en el bosque.
Mira continuamente por la ventana.
SS: Esto es; quiero mostrarles algo que no creíamos que pudiera hacer.
Video: Desde hace varios días Panbanisha no sale.
SS: Normalmente hablo del lenguaje.
Vídeo: Entonces Panbanisha hace algo inesperado.
SS: Pero como me aconsejaron no hacer lo que normalmente hago,
no les he dicho que estos simios tienen lenguaje.
Es un lenguaje geométrico.
Vídeo: Toma un trozo de tiza
y comienza a escribir algo en el suelo.
¿Qué está escribiendo?
SS: También lo está nombrando con su voz.
Video: Ahora se acerca a la Dra. Sue y empieza a escribir de nuevo.
SS: Estos son los símbolos de su teclado.
(Música)
Le hablan cuando los oprime.
Vídeo: Panbanisha le está comunicando a la Dr. Sue dónde quiere ir.
El cuadro A representa una cabaña en el bosque.
Comparen la escritura en tiza con el lexigrama del teclado.
Panbanisha comenzó a escribir lexigramas en el suelo del bosque.
"Muy bonito. Hermoso, Panbanisha."
SS: Al principio no comprendíamos lo que estaba haciendo,
hasta que lo miramos de más lejos y lo rotamos.
Video: Este lexigrama también se refiere a un lugar en el bosque.
La línea curva es muy similar a la del lexigrama.
El siguiente símbolo representa collar.
Indica el collar que Panbanisha debe llevar cuando sale.
SS: Es un requisito institucional.
Video: Este símbolo no es tan claro como los demás
pero se nota que Panbanisha está tratando de hacer una línea curva
y varias líneas rectas.
Los investigadores comenzaron a registrar lo que Panbanisha decía,
al escribir lexigramas en el suelo con tiza.
Panbanisha miró lo que hacían.
Y pronto empezó a escribir igual que ellos.
Las habilidades de los bonobo han sorprendido a los científicos de todo el mundo.
¿Cómo se desarrollaron?
SS: Encontramos que el factor más importante
que permite a los bonobo adquirir el lenguaje es no enseñarles.
Simplemente es utilizar el lenguaje a su alrededor,
porque el impulso detrás de la adquisición del lenguaje
es entender lo que están diciéndonos quienes nos importan.
Una vez que tenemos esa capacidad,
la capacidad de producir lenguaje
viene natural y libremente.
Por lo tanto, queremos crear un ambiente en el que los bonobos
se sientan a gusto con quienes interactúan.
Queremos crear un entorno en el que se diviertan
y un entorno en el cual los demás
sean personas significativas para ellos.
Video: Este ambiente revela el potencial inesperado
de Kanzi y Panbanisha.
Panbanisha goza tocando su armónica,
hasta que Nyota, que ahora tiene un año, se la roba.
Luego, mira con impaciencia la boca de su madre.
¿Está buscando el origen del sonido?
La Dra. Sue piensa que es importante permitir el desarrollo de tal curiosidad.
Esta vez Panbanisha toca el piano eléctrico.
No se le obligó a aprender el piano;
vio tocar a un investigador y se interesó.
"Adelante. Adelante. Estoy escuchando.
Haz esa parte muy rápida que hiciste. Sí, esa parte."
Kanzi toca el xilófono con ambas manos,
acompañando con entusiasmo a la Dr. Sue que canta.
Kanzi y Panbanisha
son estimulados por este ambiente lúdico,
que promueve la aparición de estas capacidades culturales.
(Risas)
"Bien, ahora los monstruos. Atrápalos.
Toma las cerezas también.
Ahora cuidado, aléjate de ellos.
Ahora puedes perseguirlos de nuevo. Tiempo de cazarlos.
Ahora tienes que alejarte. Aléjate.
Corre lejos. Corre.
Ahora podemos volver a perseguirlos. Ve por ellos.
¡Oh no!
Bien Kanzi. Muy bien. Muchas gracias."
Ninguno de nosotros, bonobo o humano pudo imaginarlo.
SS: Así que tenemos un medio ambiente de dos especies; lo llamamos "cultura panhomo".
Estamos aprendiendo a ser como ellos.
Estamos aprendiendo a comunicarnos con ellos,
en tonos realmente agudos.
Estamos aprendiendo que probablemente tienen un lenguaje en su ambiente salvaje.
Y ellos están aprendiendo a ser como nosotros.
Porque creemos que no es la biología, es la cultura.
Por lo tanto, compartimos las herramientas, la tecnología y el lenguaje
con otra especie.
Gracias.